con nuestro primer invitado del día nos
enfocamos en hacer un balance general de
la guerra en ucrania salvamos entonces a
jesús emmanuel pérez triana analista de
seguridad y defensa autor de guerras a
postmodernas puntocom y también el
flanco sur puntocom gracias jesus por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de
miércoles en directo américa de france
24 hablemos del balance general en su
opinión como se han vivido estos
primeros seis meses de confrontación
armada en ucrania hablemos de los
refugiados también los muertos los
crímenes de guerra que se han producido
en este territorio bueno lo primero es
que yo creo que ha sido una sorpresa
para todos que hayamos llegado al sexto
mes de guerra esto es como se dijo
anteriormente se previa alguna guerra
fulminante una guerra relámpago porque
si uno miraba sobre el papel las fuerzas
que se enfrentaban si hubiésemos hablado
y hemos mantenido esta conversación a
principios de febrero pues diríamos que
había una simetría de fuerzas que le
daba una ventaja considerable a rusia la
cuestión es que por un lado aquí se han
puesto sobre la mesa dos cosas uno ha
sido el apoyo y esto ha sido fundamental
ha sido importantísimo el apoyo de los
países occidentales fundamentalmente de
la otan no como una organización
colectiva pero si ha sido un apoyo sobre
todo no como organización colectiva para
no
cruzar la línea roja para rusia pero si
a nivel individual cada país ha aportado
dentro de lo posible liderado por eeuu
reino unido y luego los países como
polonia y los países bálticos eso ha
sido fundamental para que hayamos
llegado al sexto mes de guerra la otra
cuestión fundamental para que la guerra
se haya prolongado tanto es que han
quedado a la vista los problemas
profundos estructurales del ejército
ruso y esto pues se nos ha llevado una
guerra larga sangrienta y en el que
evidentemente la frustración lo que
vivimos en
la periferia de la capital en kiev en
lucha justo en el irving es cuando un
ejército se queda estancado y siente
pues un incesante ataque de la aviación
de la artillería enemiga con una
población hostil que no recibió a los
invasores con los brazos abiertos como
los rusos pensaba que iba a suceder como
había pasado en el año 2014 en la
península de crimea pues esa frustración
se vuelca sobre la población que
efectivamente además
a civiles escondidos en su casa mirando
por la ventana han estado compartiendo
información pues con las autoridades
ucranianas sobre los movimientos de
tropas y las posiciones rusas con lo
cual es esa frustración y ese odio de
los invasores pues se ha volcado y ha
generado
pues esas atrocidades que reflejaban
también lo que era en la ruptura de una
cadena de mando en un ejército que ha
tenido múltiples múltiples problemas
entonces esto ha sido una absoluta
sorpresa yo creo que para todos una
guerra tan larga tan sangrienta y hacía
acabó ha sido absolutamente una novedad
un conflicto convencional de alta
intensidad en europa esto no lo veíamos
desde la final acción a la mundial a
este nivel de intensidad claro eso
hablemos digamos del objetivo real de de
real de vladimir putin porque vemos que
las tropas rusas se centran en el este y
también en sus lucran es sobre todo en
el sur donde está la salida al mar un
punto crucial para el comercio ucraniano
también de alguna manera la subsistencia
económica de ese país hablemos de esta
táctica rusa que es realmente lo que
quiere moscú
bueno esto ha sido un tema muy
interesante y es como los objetivos
declarados han ido cambiando y si uno
mira lo como fue la invasión
esa invasión fulminante acabas que tiene
como objetivo llegar a la capital tenía
evidentemente el propósito o bien de
descabezar al gobierno ucraniano para
importar para colocar a uno pues es
dócil o bien era simplemente
provocar un colapso total de las
defensas rusia y eso los hubiese llevado
a que rusia hubiese podido imponer
condiciones a ucrania y esas condiciones
que se mencionaron al principio tenían
que ver con convertir a ucrania en un
país de lo que se dice un país colchón
desde un punto de vista geopolítico o
sea que una ucrania muy debe
militarmente neutral en el ámbito
internacional hubiese servido para
separar los países de la otan de los de
rusia ese objetivo general ruso han sido
un fracaso total porque ucrania
resistido ahora más integrada con
occidente que nunca ha solicitado su
entrada a la unión europea ha contado
con el apoyo de la otan y hemos visto
que encima que finlandia gran países
tradicionalmente neutrales eran en los
ejemplos del libro que apareció en
cualquier manual universitario sobre lo
que era un país neutral pues se han
entregado a la otan y ahora resulta que
la frontera ausbanc integra la otan y la
frontera de rusia con la otan se ha
prologado entoces en términos generales
esos objetivos rusos no se han cumplido
entonces viendo como la guerra ha
entrado en una fase de diferentes pues
los rusos han cambiado objetivos y ahora
su objetivo fundamental es consolidar
los dominios territoriales para que la
península de crimea que para ellos es
fundamental y tenga un corredor
terrestre porque hasta ahora solamente
estaba conectada con rusia a través de
un puente en el eje hecho de kerch
entonces mantener el dominio sobre esa
península requiere pues poder llevar ahí
todo tipo de materiales más tenían
problemas con el agua con la energía
entonces ahora mismo por eso es tan
importante el transcurso controlar lo
que es el sur de ucrania y lo que es la
región de ejerzan que es donde los
granas han puesto su objetivo
estaba el corredor marítimo que les
llevaba hasta odessa pero bueno no no lo
han conseguido y ese objetivo si les
hubiese permitido controlar todo lo que
era la costa ucraniana negarle la salida
al mar y entonces saber ya ha tenido un
dominio absoluto sobre el mar báltico
pero eso no ha sucedido y sea por sonido
cambiando de objetivo según han visto
las circunstancias negativas y adversas
además un poco difícil que lo consigan
digamos ahorita en el marco de este
acuerdo mediado por turquía y la 1
también para la exportación de los
granos ucranianos pero quedémonos
también en el sur de ucrania hablando
del tema tan importante como es la
península de crimea anexada por rusia en
el año 2014 el euro -que ayer también se
celebrará esta reunión internacional
sobre la península de crimea donde pues
el presidente ucranio colimense lenski
recibió todo el apoyo de occidente sobre
todo también de la unión europea
realmente primera puede pasar nuevamente
al control ucraniano recordemos también
que ayer el día de la bandera celeste y
dijo que iba a y que va a izar y que la
bandera ucraniana iba a ondear en todos
estos territorios ucranianos ocupados
por rusia y también el día hoy dijo que
iban a recuperar esta pensión entonces
qué
es que eso pase
yo lo veo la verdad que francamente
complicado en esta fase de la guerra se
ha estabilizado al frente ninguno de los
dos bandos es capaz de imponerse de una
forma decisiva y vemos que allí donde
hay algún obstáculo natural un río por
ejemplo vemos que se han ido
consolidando se han ido fortaleciendo a
cada bando entonces la el nivel de
fuerzas el nivel de superioridad militar
que es necesario para romper el frente
sobre todo en el sur de la parte más
llana del país con la vegetación más
baja y escasa o sea las emboscadas que
vimos que hacían los ucranianos a las
fuerzas rusas cerca de la capital eso no
lo amo ese tipo de combate no lo hemos
visto en el sur porque toda la parte de
gerson es una llanura entonces ahí los
ucranianos necesitarían poner sobre el
terreno un volumen de puso un número de
fuerzas en tama en número y en calidad
que ahora mismo no tienen entonces esas
declaraciones de no solamente vamos a
echar a los rusos de los territorios que
son tomados del 24 febrero sino que
encima vamos a entrar a la península de
crimea si yo lo veo muy complicado muy
complicado jesús no quiero despedirlo
sin sin hablar de esa polilla un tema
también de preocupación internacional
estás entre la nuclear
bueno pues
ahí en una situación de esta guerra lo
que aquí es fundamental es que haya unos
observadores ya hay unos actores que
sean percibidos como neutrales y que no
pertenezcan ninguno de los bandos y que
además sea personal técnico sea esto
sólo se va a resolver con la presencia
de personal técnico de la organización
internacional de la energía atómica y
observadores de naciones unidas que
puedan comprobar que esa central nuclear
está en unas condiciones de
funcionamiento y que al menos los
combates en esa se crea y una zona de
exclusión donde no haya combates es la
única solución que nos dé a todos
garantía de que esto no termina en un
desastre